para todas las abuelas de plaza de mayo
yo soy una más
porque mi historia es igual la de mis
compañeras nos juntamos con un dolor
enorme sin saber qué hacer
con desconocimiento peligro
y dejando todo
y una directora de una escuela
me subiré para buscar a ese ser querido
un hijo o una hija pero con una doble
búsqueda
porque esa hija
estaba esperando un bebé
con la edad que tengo nací en el 30 las
dictaduras me educaron
pero jamás me imaginé que iba a venir
este último golpe cívico-militar con un
proyecto tan terrorífico tan siniestro o
sea que tuve que educar me tuve que
formarme tuve que entender
pero hicimos algo maravilloso que creo
que es lo que nos permitió seguir
luchando hasta ahora nos dimos las manos
dijimos aunque estaba sola y había otra
señora como yo con el mismo dolor la
misma cara y arrimarse preguntar vos qué
te pasa y decir busco mañana vamos
juntas y así fuimos sumando a este grupo
que ya tiene y en poco tiempo vamos a
cumplir 37 años y nos miramos todavía
las que sobrevivimos porque ya muchas no
están otras están enfermas
tan distintas somos en ideología en
cultura en religión pero hay algo ese
tronco de dolor de lucha que no termina
jamás porque no creo que una mamá deje
de amar un solo día a un hijo a una hija
y más si busca al hijo al hijito
entonces fue juntarnos y empezar a
buscar
sin saber cómo ni dónde primero eran
méritos nadie nos decía nada nunca los
trajeron preparamos un ajuar un
lugarcito en la casa acomodamos la
familia después ya dejamos la familia
cambiamos el rol que teníamos de mamás
de esposas y de docentes en mi caso
y ese lugar los cupos lo ocupó mi esposo
porque a veces nos preguntan dónde están
los abuelos los abuelos estuvieron y yo
los que los calificó como los héroes
anónimos porque ellos tuvieron que tomar
el rol de seguir con los hijos que
quedaban de traer el alimento y además
de esperarnos porque salíamos y él no
sabía si vamos a volver yo me acuerdo
que una vez un poco desanimada y no sé
por qué dije ay me parece que no voy más
y él me dijo mi marido no tenés que
seguir porque las abuelas te necesitan
fue la única vez y nunca más sentí ganas
de dejar nada al contrario ustedes saben
que encontré mi nieto que nos
encontramos que estamos conviviendo
momentos
pero
yo quiero compartir con ustedes porque
mi nieto no lo encontré ellos solo a las
abuelas pero todos ustedes también
porque nos fueron dando con el correr de
estos el más largo período de democracia
argentina nos fueron dando las manos
porque fueron entendiendo que la
dictadura nos tocó a todos que no tiene
que volver a pasar que hay que rescatar
estos desaparecidos con vida o sea que
mi nieto es el nieto de todos por eso
fíjense que pasó algo maravilloso ahí
como una especie de sonrisa general en
nuestro país a partir de este encuentro
no sé si es por la lucha de esta mujer
de 37 años desde el amor sin odios sin
rencores
simplemente queriendo que esto no vuelva
a pasar que se tengan hijos para que
vivan en libertad que puedan pensar
disentir pero ser hermanos por eso me
parece que este encuentro multitudinario
maravilloso de todos ustedes en este
espacio cultural
debe cimentar la convivencia a pesar de
las diferencias fíjense las abuelas como
les digo hoy en día está discutimos de
cosas en las que no compartimos pero
cuando hay que decidir algo firmes y
hemos dejado por suerte y yo a veces
digo que con cerrar a que diga gracias a
la vida a pesar del dolor porque mi hija
dio la vida sabiendo que había que
cambiar y están cambiando las cosas y
estamos dejando caminos abiertos
inexplorados uno de ellos la ciencia no
hay en el mundo un banco nacional de
datos genéticos donde abuelas están
buscando esos nietos que una dictadura
les robó somos el único país que tiene
una historia similar y con la búsqueda
de estos bebés entonces y adultos pero
qué alegría cuando el encuentro se
produce la felicidad yo me siento más
joven me siento mejor a mí sí tengo
ganas de tirar este bastón
pero que también digo miren lo tengo
porque las abuelas nunca nos
arrodillamos siempre caminamos de pie
con fuerza con empeño con respeto porque
no es necesario agredir para conseguir
la justicia y la justicia está llegando
yo creo que dejamos un granito de arena
en esta democracia que esperemos que sea
la democracia para siempre yo
les deseo
les deseo en
en estos breves minutos de charla
lo mejor para todos creo que si están
acá es porque son los argentinos que
merecen respeto que merecen ser
escuchados y darle satisfacción a sus
demandas lo más importante es no estar
solos lo más importante es no cansarse
porque la perseverancia triunfa miren yo
37 años hoy acá
les digo a ustedes gracias por ayudarme
a encontrar mi nieto porque vale la pena
luchar muchísimas gracias muchísimas
gracias